I want to talk a little bit about a piece
that Joel Mathes wrote in the week about how
Donald Trump just can't stand, that Joe Biden
is stealing the spotlight from him and Trump's
been hiding out at the White House and at
his golf courses.
But that's actually making the problem even
worse.
And Joe Mathes in his piece likens it to Norma
Desmond in Sunset Boulevard.
And you might remember in Sunset Boulevard,
Norma Desmond is she ends up long after she
is no longer, you know, the Hollywood star
that she once was.
She's surrounded by sycophants and enablers
and yes, men and yes, women, long after she
stops commanding any respect, sort of living
out a fantasy, living out a fake existence
for lack of a better term.
And the point the analogy here is that Donald
Trump's behavior only makes sense if you go
beyond questions like could this strategy
work to steal the election from Joe Biden?
Does Trump really think that he actually won
Pennsylvania?
Once you get beyond those initial questions
and you go to, well, what Trump is doing here
is desperately trying to cling to the spotlight,
both for ego and vanity, as much as fears
of being investigated and potentially prosecuted
after he's out of office.
That's the framework in which this starts
to make sense.
And the more that the spotlight turns towards
Joe Biden, the angrier that Donald Trump gets,
which explains his tweets over the weekend
saying, why is Joe Biden forming a cabinet?
Why is Joe Biden moving ahead when we still
are fighting this and we actually won?
And the reality is that this is when the spotlight
should be turning to Joe Biden for two reasons.
No.
One, in general, when you have a new president
elect, the president that's outgoing is called
a lame duck president.
That's because while they are still president,
the next four years are going to be decided
upon from an executive, from the executive
branch standpoint, by Joe Biden, not by Donald
Trump.
And so Donald Trump has these waning days
during which he is president.
So in general, the attention now turns to
the president elect.
What is the cabinet going to look like?
What are the day one priorities?
What are the 100 day priorities, et cetera?
But Donald Trump is exacerbating the speed
at which the spotlight is turning to Joe Biden
because Donald Trump isn't even working anymore.
Trump stop doing presidential work.
Months before the election, he was just campaigning,
not dealing with coronavirus, not getting
his PDB presidential daily briefings.
And he's barely been seen in public since
the election.
He's scheduled to do some kind of turkey thing
today related to Thanksgiving.
He's not actually taking questions since the
election.
It's probably been about a month since he's
taken press questions.
We have one hundred year pandemic, which Trump
all but ignored.
And Joe Biden has a coronavirus task force
and is taking it seriously.
So, of course, Americans in the media are
turning to Joe Biden.
If you look at Joe Biden and Trump, only one
of them is still dealing with coronavirus
or is dealing with coronavirus.
And it's Joe Biden.
So who are you going to turn to?
Joe Biden is the one choosing a cabinet that
is going to have to lead us out of this mess
economically and from a public health standpoint.
So, of course, that's what we're talking about
and evaluating.
Is Joe Biden making the right choices or not?
And how are these people going to govern that
Joe Biden is selecting?
So when Trump doesn't recognize Biden's win,
finally now allowing the formal transition
to start, which is the closest we're going
to get to a concession from Trump while still
claiming that he actually won, he is desperately
trying to cling not just to the.
Presidency, but to the spotlight because of
his ego and his narcissism and Joel Mathis
does point out that some of this is the media's
fault by continuing to talk about Joe Biden's
apparent victory and the network, the networks
like OEI and a Newsmax, not even using the
term apparent victor and just placating any
insane notion about Donald Trump being the
actual winner, they do encourage the system
to keep it going.
But it's mostly Donald Trump.
And we know Trump hates being ridiculed.
We know Trump hates being mocked.
And we saw that with his quick distancing
from that whacked out lawyer, Sydney Powell,
when she went on Newsmax and said there would
be evidence of biblical proportions soon to
prove fraud.
She was instantly fired.
And in fact, it was one of these retroactive.
She never really was working for us anyway
because the mockery is what got to Donald
Trump that does actually get to him.
So it's possible that more mockery of Trump
will get him to do more to maybe to actually
use the term I concede and call Joe Biden.
But all that really matters is that Donald
Trump yesterday did finally say via Twitter,
I'm allowing the transition to happen formally,
even though I'm going to keep fighting.
And eventually Donald Trump will leave regardless.
Joe Biden will still become president, but
it's going to be all the more embarrassing
for Donald Trump.
In the meantime, the best we can do is all
move on to talking about Joe Biden's plans,
his cabinet selections, his coronavirus task
force.
And we're doing it.
And I have to tell you, I am as I've said
before, Trump would be better.
Another four years of Trump would be better
for the business of The David Pakman Show.
There's no doubt it would be worse for the
country.
And I am actually enjoying starting to look
into the backgrounds of Joe Biden's cabinet
picks.
What is Joe Biden likely to do on day one
via executive order?
What is Biden going to do in his first week
in terms of the virus?
What are the first 100 day priorities?
How is Biden's secretary of Homeland Security
going to deal with immigration policy?
We're actually getting back into substance.
And I heard from a bunch of people yesterday,
longtime viewers of the show, who have said,
you know, I've been a fan for a long time.
I love what you do, but I am already feeling
a breath of fresh air and just getting back
to talking about policy, even if we don't
agree with everything Joe Biden does.
Certainly we will not.
The guy who looked at the solar eclipse, his
time is up.
The guy who suggested bleach injections, sort
of like a cleaning to treat the virus.
He is going to be leaving the guy who used
the Sharpie to adjust a hurricane map for
political gain.
He is exiting stage left in eight weeks.
And we are all the better for it.
And we are we are going to continue moving
forward.
And I am glad to say that hopefully progressive
media is on the path to becoming dramatically
more substantive as we get closer and closer
to Joe Biden's swearing in.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
And while you're there, you can follow me
on Instagram at David Pakman
as well.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.